hike you know check community I'm  Isabella Mona I can't wait for you to  see my new movie Dora and the lost city  of gold in cinemas soon it's a great big  fun adventure and you won't want to miss  it I'll see there Dora for dinner if you  think you know door she'll grow out of  it  think again Dora this isn't the jungle  it's high school it's life or death  so if I don't talk to you don't take a  person oh okay I'll just try to survive  high school's a horrible nightmare are  you I'm glad you brought it I'm just  kidding I don't actually care we're onto  something big Dora an ancient city made  of gold we're gonna break some rules  we're coming with you Prima  [Music]  oh look barber on a knife on the field  trip everybody  it's a jungle puzzle  the Jumbo is perfectly safe  [Music]  seriously you had that in your backpack  too  Dora and the lost city of gold excuse me  hey chili con carne will be gee  [Music]